Wren: So, we took that 3D model that Sam had downloaded and augmented.
You can see here it's like it's got these weird fracture points like, like break this.
It's actually already broken.
We also have the GoPro Session.
You can put it here in the middle.
The issue is that this is so low down that it's like all the GoPro's are all gonna be in the shot.
Just modeled a quick little thing here.
Basically put the little GoPro here in
that and this will sit in the rig here.
It's weird that there aren't really any
dimensions for the session online.
But I just- I literally just want to know
how thick it was
how long it was
how wide it was.
I measured it myself.
It is not 35 millimeters it is 38 millimeters.
Cmike: Hey Jake.
Jake: Oh hey.
Alright, so what do you need to make a Metal Gear Solid Bionic Arm?
Well, first things first, you need an
under-layer.
One left-handed black glove.
One left sleeve of a black shirt.
Crafting foam; You can buy this online
but it's basically like yoga foam.
Outside of a Clorox disinfecting wipes can.
You know, materials should come cheap.
Heat gun; use with adult supervision or...
you know what to do.
Is it latex paint?
Let's see what happens.
It's just like kindergarten.
You know, I was telling Wren earlier,
Wren might be the engineer who became a VFX artist and creator,
and I'm the lawyer who became a prop maker.
And that's what you need,
you start from there.
Wren: Sent this over to Spencer over in Stress Level Zero
To print it on their 3D printer.
So let's go check out if it turned out well.
Wren: Wait, do you have records to play on it?
Sam: I got like one.
Wren: That's enough.
Sam: Ha, yep.
Wren: Haha.
There's the guy I wanted to see.
Spencer: You've been looking for me?
Wren: Do you know if the print turned out well?
Spencer: Yes.
Wren: It did?
Wren: *excited clap* Let's go check it out!
There it is!
Makerbot Replicator 2X.
Wren: Shall we?
Spencer: You shall.
Wren: Moment of truth.
It is...ok I don't want to break it.
So, hopefully this will fit.
*gasp* it does!
A little tighter next time, maybe. *Ba-dum-tss*
Now for the second moment of truth, if you don't mind holding this.
I brought the session!
*drumroll*
Nooooooooo!
We reprinted this piece.
One percent bigger.
It finally fits now
and it's way tighter in the hole.
It goes all the way down so it's like we
have all the angles looking outwards.
The only piece you're missing from a rig like this is
literally just the bottom patch.
In effects, you can literally go in and like throw a
tile down at the bottom.
Now this rig is entirely finished and in fact we could probably actually use this for the final thing.
Well, it wiggles a bit, but I mean it's not gonna be moving so it's not a big deal.
Niko: Amazon! Our favorite retailer!
Wait, are these the cool chairs or are these the dumb chairs?
Cmike: These are the same chairs that we all are getting.
Niko: Those ones?
Cmike: Yeah.
Niko: Oh, well I got a special chair for myself.
So, we're gonna have three nice chairs?
*Niko mumbling*
Sam: Get down!
Huh
Sam: Oh, what?
Hehe it bounced off the handle.
Niko: Can you give me the Arnold Schwarzenegger quote one more time?
Sam: Get this Choppa off of me!
Niko: Take that!!
What uuupp?!
I did it!
Sam: Screw that wall!
*misses*
*mumbling* I hate knives.
*sticks the landing*
All: OOOOHHHHH!
Niko: I love knives!
*laughter*